college-educated women initiate divorce
ninety percent of the time
I don't know what are the stats say
isn't it usually people aren't happy in
the relationships
um it depends what study you look at
I've looked at like
um sometimes it's Financial sometimes
I've seen infidelity I think as a high
one I've seen people are just generally
not happy with the relationship
um differences
that's one
I was just curious anecdotally
I don't know very many divorces with
college degrees so I can't really say no
oh okay why do you what do they say
I mean I don't ask them they're like my
mom's friends I don't I don't ask them
for the behind the scenes of their
divorces
do you feel like do you asking that
question you feel like something in
college makes
women wanted no I mean I feel like women
just have a hard time
I mean I think it kind of goes back to
like women out earning men have a hard
time respecting the men they're with
that's not true that's not true that's
not true I actually read it again
it's not true I read into that data and
he explained why so a lot of times the
women reported that they had way too
much responsibility in the marriage so
they were expected to be in charge of
the household duties and still work a
job and they add to come on what percent
of modern women actually cook it was it
was that is
20 of the men when both parents are
working only 20 actually reported to
doing household duties that's scary when
you're both working and I'm just saying
the shit's automated nowadays I mean you
have a washing machine a dishwasher
but as much as it's on as much as it's
on a Minute Men still don't do it
when you get older and you manage a
household on your own Pearl you'll see
how [__] annoying it is when you're
working and then you come home and
everything is [__] up and horrible and
nobody's [__] cleaning anything yeah
that is a totally valid reason for
divorce of course chores to break up a
home our family have you lived in a
filter hole
if it is consistent where you'll
consistently having to have that burden
upon yourself you keep telling them
please can you clean up like it's so
funny because like lifelong friends from
like grade school to high school well
dormant college and then hate each other
forever over like bad dorm roommates and
that's not even a relationship so yeah
of course I think stuff like this is
perfectly valid I think I think
splitting up and splitting up splitting
up duties in the household is like one
of the most important parts of like a
relationship because it's where you're
spending most of the time together this
is why I say people get trigger when I
say I don't think you're even dating
until you live together because until
you live together you don't really know
who the other person's like and once you
start living together and you see what
the household duties are like then you
get a feel for what the relationship is
I mean I just I just think that like I
don't know I feel like that stuff can be
worked out chores like hold on wait do
you understand wait wait hold on you're
not saying anything oh you do this
intentionally we're like I don't know
about that we're telling you I'm telling
you that I mean you're giving your
opinion I'm giving I'm not giving an
opinion I'm saying that in a house so
there's not an opinion I'm putting it
back in a house delineation of chores is
one of the most important things that if
somebody's constantly destroying the
bathroom leaving clothes everywhere
leaving dirty food in the sink they
can't clean their their dishes or
whatever like these things will it will
destroy anything over time yeah but
that's what that's what she said she
said I'm sure we can work it out
though
there may be maybe these women that are
making all this money that you know
they're making so much money working
they don't want to do the house chores
maybe they should go and get an older
guy with more money so they can go on
and play a maid
yeah you guys maybe they should do that
thing man okay no you what listen to
what you just said you said they're
leaving the guys that make less money
because they're expected to make money
and do the house and you're saying how
hard it is because you're at home and
you're doing all these shows okay then
don't be with a guy that makes less
money find a guy that makes more money
and then you don't have to do chores
because you employed a maid and a cook
okay but then like you said but then
young guys young guys can't complain
then that girls won't date their own age
because they because guys can't do house
chores then you'd be like oh sorry you
know you're 25 years old you have to be
single to your 35 and learn how to do
the dishes
five percent of men can even afford that
to be like oh yeah in the UK and what
percentage and what percentage of women
are these high flyer women that are
making six figures a year no I'm not no
I'm not okay no I'm just asking I'm just
asking you I'm just asking you because
you're going you're making this point
about these women that make so much
money and then they're making they make
so much money I'll speak into the
magnets they work so having a full-time
job on average men or women are
so obviously
obviously I'm not saying that high
earners all I'm saying is they're
working that's it so the the solution is
men should understand that their women
are also working so how can I help
knowing that we're doing the same job
how can I make her life easy because
she's making my life easy by doing the
chores well Paul said that but Pearl
said that I'm sure there's a way you
could work it out so that the house
chores can be you know easy and good for
everybody
let me ask a question do you think so do
you think the man should do all the
house tours because he makes less money
and most of them most of them yes most
of them cool okay do you why do you
think they're getting divorced do you
think divorce is fun that the because
they're college educated and they hate
men they're just like I'm just gonna
divorce because I I hate all men like
why do you think I get a divorce I think
women divorce for no reason all the time
that's absolutely [__] you just need
to talk to more people then because
that's not true
you've never seen my street interviews
then I've done so many Street interviews
I talked to random strangers on the
street all the time and you and you find
women that get divorced like oh you know
I just wanted to get divorced yeah but
the reason
oh my God you're actually a child what
do you think love is you're just like
romantically going away to Venice like
every year and that's like like no a
relationship requires a lot of
deliberate work and things like hold on
hold on things like chores are where
relationships start to break down and
it'll steamroll into bigger things like
a guy not doing chores ever might be a
guy that you don't want to [__] anymore
and then you not having sex ever it
might be you guys just don't get along
anymore and then like three months into
it you [__] hate each other and you
don't know why and you're not sleeping
together even you're not having any sex
you don't do anything together and it
starts over small [__] but anybody
that's been in any relationship long
term I don't know how old you guys are
but if you've been in real relationships
long term these little things will pile
up and [__] kill you they're like the
worst things relationships are not like
this puppy like romantic love constantly
that's doing the small things every
single day to make sure the relations
work yeah okay but you're just like lol
chores like I don't know what that means
they like why do you have to let it get
to that point I feel like it's the guys
that aren't doing the chores yeah
controversial to say that I think chores
is a crazy reason to get divorced and
break up a home and put your kid at
every statistical disadvantage that you
possibly could no because it's not just
choice I just think that's
a choice you probably can't pick your
kid up on time you probably aren't
paying attention to the needs of your
[__] wife okay you probably aren't
keeping other points like you can't do
chores everything else in life is
probably falling apart you should have
picked a better guy and then you know
what they need divorced
once you have kids it's not about you
anymore I mean I don't really if you
don't know if someone's get divorced
fired but like I just think once you
have kids it's not about you you can't
help me stop using this excuse of just
pick a better guy as a as an answer
every time women aren't happy about
situation can we just hold men
accountable and just say please can you
help your woman out if they okay okay
I'll help you they don't have enough
options
thank you wow
but no one was arguing that though no
one was saying that dementia do your
chores or do what he needs to do it
my whole argument is that I think
divorce is stupid over chores I think
that's stupid
I feel like you've never lived with
someone that like she hasn't like that's
the only that's the only way you don't
understand you've never lived with
somebody that is like you come home so
tired you know you've cleaned the house
you're ready to just sleep in your bed
and the house is a pigstylist it's funny
was you in a relationship with a bum
then no you've done it so you sound like
you've done it have you been in that
situation I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go
into that detail now but you're you're
talking about like Pearl hasn't done
that so obviously if you're if you're
talking from that standpoint it sounds
like you have experience that's all I'm
asking oh so you've done it then
no
okay so you're basically in the same
position no you shouldn't really because
you're in the same position
I think it's really funny I think it's
really funny that when we have these
conversations we say LOL just chores L
will destroys but then when I go on any
red pill podcast and I say what is a
perfect wife what's a perfect woman the
only thing that the men say are women
that do chores I want a woman that takes
care of the house that cooks me a clean
meal that makes sure that my home is in
order those are chores that's all that
is King there's other relationships than
just men and women I've lived with other
people and I know what I'm talking about
so that's just because it's normal but
we're talking about science specific
though now we're talking about the chaos
of not doing chores in the house and
what that brings to your home your home
is supposed to have peace I understand
that but we're talking about something
specific though all right thanks and
also just to add on if 90 of college
student women are initiating divorces
that means a lot wait what's wrong with
my mind
you turn your head you're not like you
have to move like you've got to be
speaking like right covering my face
you've got to lift it while like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah push it down
yeah yeah that's it thank you again
there yeah oh wow just put it just put
it down just face it towards you it
doesn't move like that like that it does
move it just knocks me out it's like
it's gonna knock me out loads of hinges
there yeah yeah come on bro you got this
okay see what I mean it just moves
we're working okay it's so awkward
genius yeah thank you yeah okay okay
don't touch it well yeah the point I
wanted to make is if 90 of college
students women are basically initiating
the divorce that means there are a lot
of men that are bombs do you not think
no it just means you probably make bad
choices
so those are 90 all of them made bad
well I agree but it's the men and women
making bad choices if we say that right
she's not she's not saying that oh she's
not saying that bro don't help her okay
I just feel like when when the stats are
so high like if it was like 60 you can
say it's just you can put it down just
the bad choices but when it's 90 I never
said all though I just said a lot
yeah but it's also proven that a lot of
men are bombs is it is that right yeah
because a lot of women are feeling the
same way because you feel because women
feel a certain way that means it makes
it a fact
what if they're reporting it a lot of
women are reporting to say what exactly
they're reporting that one of the
reasons that they've initiated divorce
are things like the man's not
understanding helping out with other
responsibilities that's one that's one
aspect yeah exactly but that's what do
you think you think the women do you
think the women that uh just choose men
over superficial things and when it
doesn't work out because he's a Chad and
Tyrone and he cheats do you think they
they add that to the list as well do
they do they come out with
accountability and say you know what I
picked horribly I picked the guy because
he was six foot six and he had a big
Willy do you think they put that down as
well no of course they wouldn't of
course exactly so you're you're only
hyper focused on one thing your hyper
Focus because we've been talking about
for the last 20 minutes this one aspect
okay let's talk about something else so
another reason that they reported
initiating the divorce is because they
don't have to tolerate bad behavior back
in the days bad behavior so back in the
days women went through a lot of abuse
Financial abuse emotional abuse because
of the fact that they didn't have
Financial Security they married just to
get that Financial Security and now
their college bro they're going to earn
a lot of money when when they graduate
so now it's like I don't need you to
really rely on I don't need to rely on
you for financial support I can actually
make decisions because of the way I feel
now now you're not making me happy
you're not trying to make me happy so
I'm just gonna leave I've tried to com
like communicate with you and we're not
getting anywhere so now it's really
because women can as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible